2023年我刚入职的时候，压根没人会把Anthropic和Claude跟编程扯上关系。
我想回到Anthropic刚起步的时候。我记得当时想，老兄，这些人根本没戏。OpenAI领先太多了。
那时候，我发现大家开始不只是用这些模型来自动补全代码，而是真的让它们写大段的代码了。这让我们看到了机会，可以把Opus 3训练得更好。那是个转折点。
我总是想，一年后的寒假，当所有人都回家能写代码时，Opus 4.5会是什么样子。
Opus 4.5的神奇之处在于，我们不仅有模型，还有了一个载体，比如像Cloud Code这样优秀的产品体验。没有Cloud Code这样的产品，Opus 4.5就不会有那样的高光时刻。
而如果没有Opus 4.5，Cloud Code也不可能以那种速度获得用户。
我想谈谈产品角色正在如何变化
对我们的团队来说。推动用户价值的方法就是找到正确的用户反馈。在评估上，我们团队有句话叫评估就是新的产品需求文档。
这也是Gary Tan一直在讲的。如果你现在愿意每年花十万美元在token上，那你过的就是2028年人们的生活方式。
你得像关注像素一样关注token的消耗。你必须用模型来想出好的、更好的、甚至绝妙的想法。没有别的替代方法。现在人们应该对AI工具更有野心，
因为它们的能力实在太强了。
我问团队的一件事是，假设Claude 8出来了，用户的行为会有什么变化？这对你今天的工作方式意味着什么？
今天我的嘉宾是Diane Penn，她是Anthropic公司AI研究与实验室团队的产品负责人。三年前，她作为第一位技术产品经理加入了Anthropic，这在AI领域里算是一段漫长的时间了，当时产品团队只有五个工程师。
她帮助推出了从Claw 2到Fable的每一个Anthropic模型。她还帮助孵化和推出了Claw Code、MCP、Skills、Claw Design，以及像计算机使用、工具使用和推理这样的核心能力。
能和这样一个站在AI和产品管理核心位置的人交谈，总是一件非常愉快且开阔眼界的事情。很难想象有谁比Anthropic研究实验室团队的产品负责人更能洞察行业的发展方向了。
在开始之前，别忘了去lenniesproass.com看看，那里有一年免费的、全球最热门、设计最精美的AI产品，专为Lenny的新闻通讯订阅者准备。
那么，让我们有请Diane Penn。Diane，非常感谢你来到这里，欢迎来到播客。
谢谢你，Lenny。很高兴再次见到你。
我想回到Anthropic的起点，早期那些日子。我记得Anthropic刚成立的时候，大概几年，第一个模型发布时，应该是三年前左右吧。
那时候真是
三年前。我记得当时就感觉，天哪，这些人根本没戏。OpenAI领先太多了，他们到底在想什么？这怎么可能？OpenAI已经赢了，太晚了。嗯，现在情况大不相同了。
我最近看到的数据是，Anthropic的年收入大概有500亿美元。这相当于以前那些非常成功的公司上市时的估值。据说Anthropic
每年都能赚这么多。你作为最早的产品经理之一加入，当时只有大约五名工程师。你加入时，模型甚至还没推出。在Anthropic的早期
是怎样的？初期有哪些让人意想不到的事情？
我想，Anthropic今天能成，很大程度上跟早期打下的基础是分不开的。我是2023年加入的，就像你说的，当时产品工程师就五个人。整个API团队只有一名工程师。
如果你相信业务的话。嗯，我认为很大一部分原因是公司文化非常强大，我觉得这是我想对对公司感兴趣的人强调的一点。我们确实在践行使命、文化和价值观。
嗯，那种能量非常像初创公司。我想你说得对，早期我们确实在努力寻找自己的定位。我觉得一方面是关于技术本身，
但技术如何为用户带来价值，为社会带来价值，这可能是什么呢？我觉得早期我们就在以不同的方式探索这个问题。比如我们一开始做的是cloud.ai，有点像另一个聊天助手，然后逐渐演变出工具使用等功能。
嗯，我觉得我们真正开始进入状态的时刻之一是推出了像是“金门大桥Claude”这样的东西。我不知道你还记不记得。不记得了。
>> 嗯，这个功能实际上只上线了大约24小时。我们刚刚在2024年初发表了早期可解释性研究之一。其中一个例子就是，你可以在模型层内获得所谓的特征，
这些特征表达了某些主题。比如研究人员识别出的一个主题是“要点列表写作”，另一个是“人物和地点”。而其中一个频繁出现且引起共鸣的特征是金门大桥。
所以当你实际上调高那个特征时，Claude就会对金门大桥着迷。也就是说，它每次回应都会提到金门大桥。
所以如果你说：“给我一个做意大利面的食谱。”它会说：“这是食谱，而橙色就像国际橘色，也就是金门大桥的颜色。”所以这真的非常古怪，
而我们非常希望在那种情况下，把这个体验带给大众，带给那些刚开始使用Claude的人。于是整个体验我们实际上在24小时内就上线了，
这需要工程、产品、设计以及研究团队一起协作，我们为此感到非常自豪。我想可能只有2000人看到了吧，说实话。
但这让我们觉得：哦，我们真的能带来新的用户体验，以不同的、真实的方式展示我们的研究，而且是以非常初创公司的速度。对我来说，这就像是其中一个可能
隐形的转折点，我们开始找到自己的身份，能够构建产品、体验，不同于竞争对手已经展示过的东西。我认为显然，像实验室、Clog代码等等，我们之后就开始
以我们真正认为的世界如何思考AI、如何让AI更贴近公众的方式来定义自己。但这是一个非常自下而上的文化。所以整个体验都是自下而上的。我看到
工程师、设计师自愿贡献时间来工作。所以我总是喜欢用这个作为例子，来说明早期是什么样的，但文化和价值观自那以后我认为一直保持不变。
>> 本期节目由我们的季度赞助商WorkOS呈现。OpenAI、Anthropic、Cursor、Vercel、Replit、Sierra、Clay以及其他数百家成功的公司有什么共同点？它们都由WorkOS驱动。
如果你正在为企业构建产品，你肯定感受过集成单点登录、SCIM、审计日志以及大公司要求的其他功能的痛苦。WorkOS将这些交易障碍转化为
即插即用的API，它有一个专为B2B SaaS打造的现代化开发者平台。说实话，我投资的每一家开始向上市场扩张的初创公司最终都会使用WorkOS。这是因为他们是最好的。
无论你是想获得第一个企业客户的种子轮初创公司，还是正在全球扩张的独角兽，WorkOS都是实现企业就绪和释放增长的最快途径。它本质上就是企业功能的Stripe。请访问
workos.com开始使用，或者直接去他们的Slack，那里有真正的工程师等着回答你的问题。WorkOS让你通过愉快的API、全面的文档和流畅的开发者体验更快地构建。前往workos.com，
今天就让你的应用企业就绪。还有哪些其他重要的转折点，你觉得Anthropic从最初只是一个试图与OpenAI这个巨头竞争的实验室，发展到今天的样子？有哪些时刻让你觉得“哇，这真的改变了局面”？
绝对是当我们训练和测试Opus 3的时候。我认为那是一个关键时刻，那时我们公司可能还不到200人，
但非常清楚的是，我们需要也想要创造一个前沿模型，这对于我们触达用户、消费者以及展示研究来说非常重要。
我们也在寻找为什么有人会选择Claude？这是一个核心问题，也是早期我们经常被问到的问题。我认为随着Opus 3的推出，你知道，它是在
2024年3月初发布的。但在那之前有很多个月，各个团队——推理、研究、微调、预训练——在不同的时间点为了共同的目标而努力，我想所有参与其中的人都
真的非常自豪。我记得作为产品经理，研究团队，还有我自己，我们都在大约12月的时候，各自在家里，也就是父母家里，看到大家背景里的各种景象，
他们的童年房间，每个人都拼命工作，努力搞清楚我们到底是在为什么训练模型？它是否以正确的方式出现？所以我认为这对于建立很多信任来说非常有力。
而且我们的很多研究负责人实际上从那时起就成了现在领导强化学习、领导我们角色对齐工作的那些人。所以那种基础信任我认为也帮助我们现在在产品和研究方面与任何生产模型都合作得很好，因为我们早期就一起在战壕里摸爬滚打。
然后我认为还有一些事情，比如识别出编码很重要。对吧？2023年我刚开始的时候，没有人会把Anthropic、Claude和编码放在同一个句子里。我认为当时的竞争对手模型比如GPT4有些用于编码，但只是众多用例之一。而我看到的一件事是，人们开始使用这些代码模型，不仅仅是为了代码，不仅仅是代码自动补全，而是实际编写长篇幅的代码，这对我们来说是不是一个机会，来训练Opus 3让它在这方面更擅长，结果从训练角度来看这只是一个相对较小的改变，但它最终帮助我们在早期竞争中实现了差异化，并为用户带来了价值。实际上还吸引了很多非常早期的Claude爱好者和开发者，因为我们提供了他们当时认为不可能的价值。
[3] 没人会把Anthropic、Claude和编码联系在一起。我想当时的竞争对手模型例如GPT4在某种程度上被用于编码，但它只是众多用例之一。而且我看到的一件事是，人们开始使用这些代码模型，不仅仅是为了代码，不只是代码自动补全，而是实际编写长篇幅的代码，这是否是我们训练Opus 3使其更擅长的机会，最终从训练角度来看，这只是一个相对较小的改动，但最终帮助我们在早期提升了竞争力，并吸引了用户。同时也带来了很多非常早期的Claude爱好者与开发者，因为我们提供了他们认为当时不可能实现的价值。
从训练的角度来看，最终这是一个相对较小的改变，但最终帮助我们在早期实现了竞争差异化，并吸引了用户。同时也带来了很多非常早期的Claude爱好者和开发者，因为我们提供了他们认为当时不可能实现的价值。
从训练的角度看，最终这是一个相对较小的变化，但它最终帮助我们在早期竞争中对用户形成了差异化，并真正吸引了很多非常早期的Claude爱好者和开发者，因为我们提供了他们当时认为不可能的价值。
他们当时认为不可能的价值。
“你谈到Opus 3真是很有趣，那已经是很久以前的事了，很难想到那是一个重大的转折点，所以听到这内部是一个大里程碑，真的很有意思。这几乎感觉像是你们建立的那种信心，‘哇，我们真的能推出前沿模型’，而今天与我们现在拥有的相比，这并不算太了不起。我经常想到的是Opus 4.5，有趣的是大约一年后，也是在寒假期间，大家都在家能写代码。那是另一个大里程碑吗？”
“你觉得Opus 4.5又是一个大时刻吗？”
“是的。Opus 4.5绝对是另一个重要的时刻。我认为Opus 4.5的神奇之处在于，我们现在不仅有了一个模型，还有一个载体，比如像Cloud Code这样的优秀产品体验。我们在团队中经常说，你需要前沿产品才能拥有前沿模型，并让人们感受到前沿模型的魔力。而且我认为，在那之前的几个月里，我们深有体会。”
“是的。Opus 4.5绝对是另一个重要的时刻。我认为Opus 4.5的神奇之处在于，我们现在不仅有了一个模型，还有一个载体，比如像Cloud Code这样出色的产品体验。我们在团队里常说，你需要前沿产品才能拥有前沿模型，并让人们感受到前沿模型的魔力。而且我觉得，在那之前的几个月里，我们就深深体会到了。”
“是的。Opus 4.5绝对是另一个重要的时刻。我认为Opus 4.5的神奇之处在于，我们现在不仅有了一个模型，还有一个载体，比如像Cloud Code这样出色的产品体验。我们在团队里常说，你需要前沿产品才能拥有前沿模型，并让人们感受到前沿模型的魔力。而且我觉得，在那之前的几个月里，我们就深深体会到了它的魔力。”
“但实际上，模型达到了一定水平的智能，使得用户能够在广泛的层面上体验前沿智能，并在新的用例中允许它以代理的方式端到端地运行事情。我认为那就是转折点。这实际上两者兼备。我认为Opus 4.5如果没有像Cloud Code这样的产品就不会有那样的时刻，而Cloud Code我认为如果没有Opus 4.5就不会有那种加速的采用。”
“并且实际上，模型达到了一个智能水平，在非常广泛的层面上，用户可以在新用例中体验前沿智能，并允许它以代理方式端到端地运行事情。我认为那就是转折点。这实际上是两者的结合。我认为如果没有像Cloud Code这样的产品，Opus 4.5就不会有那个时刻，而如果没有Opus 4.5，Cloud Code也不会有那种加速的采用。”
“所以，沿着这个话题说，有趣的是，如果你回顾达里奥的所有预测，他就是说编码将在一年内百分之百解决之类的话。他一直强调我们将用AI来编写所有的代码。我记得当时所有人都说，‘不可能，这太复杂了。AI怎么可能真正擅长这种人类做的非常复杂的事情？不，这将在很长一段时间内由人类来做。’他完全正确。他还经常谈论的另一件事就是这个指数曲线，我们现在正处于其中。那就是他现在描述的方式。我们正处于指数曲线上。我记得不久前，新模型发布时，大家都说，‘好了，我们结束了。没有更多的上升空间了，它正在趋于平稳，已经结束了，没有更多的增长空间了。’而现在则相反。现在我们身处其中，如果你考虑指数曲线，我们现在就在指数曲线的内部，这必然意味着每一个改进都是巨大的飞跃，因为我们正处于那个曲棍球棒部分。身处这个疯狂的历史时刻内部是什么感觉？AI进步如此之快，如此多的东西正在被解锁。那是什么感觉？人们应该如何为AI越来越多的进步加速做准备？我喜欢在团队中说的一个观点是，当互联网从新奇事物转变为每个人都能使用的东西时，我们大多数人还没有积极参与工作，感觉那只是人类正在经历的事情。我认为类比是有帮助的，所以类比一下就是，我认为有几件事，第一是适应性变得非常重要。我认为我们有评估、安全方面的安全测试红队、能力和产品方面的新原型产品如Cloud Code Tag等，但很难预测确切的时刻或确切的模型。所以当面对新信息时，适应性如何让你做出更好的决策，而不是保持同样的计划。所以这种敏捷性非常重要。我认为另一个部分是，如何真正地进行第一性原理思考，推理下一步是什么？那又怎么样？我们如何投资新产品？我们如何向用户解释差异？所以我认为处于那个指数中的很多体验就是，把握节奏，理解你如何运作并做出更好的决策，然后应用第一性原理思考去做一些事情。”
“所以，继续这个话题，有趣的是，如果你回顾达里奥的所有预测，他就是说编码将在大约一年内百分之百解决之类的话。他一直谈论我们将用AI做所有的代码。我记得当时大家都说，‘不可能，这太复杂了。AI怎么可能真正擅长这种人类做的非常复杂的事情？不，这将在很长一段时间内由人类来做。’他完全正确。他还经常谈论的另一件事就是这个指数曲线，我们现在正处于其中。那就是他现在描述的方式。我们正处于指数曲线上。我记得不久前，新模型发布时，大家都说，‘好了，我们结束了。没有更多的上升空间了，它正趋于平稳，已经结束了，没有更多的增长空间了。’而现在则相反。现在我们身处其中，如果你考虑指数曲线，我们现在就在指数曲线的内部，这必然意味着每一个改进都是巨大的飞跃，因为我们正处于那个曲棍球棒部分。身处这个疯狂的历史时刻内部是什么感觉？AI进步如此之快，如此多的东西正在被解锁。那是什么感觉？人们应该如何为AI越来越多的进步加速做准备？我喜欢在团队中说的一个观点是，当互联网从新奇事物转变为每个人都能使用的东西时，我们大多数人还没有积极参与工作，感觉那只是人类正在经历的事情。我认为类比是有帮助的，所以类比一下就是，我认为有几件事，第一是适应性变得非常重要。我认为我们有评估、安全方面的安全测试红队、能力和产品方面的新原型产品如Cloud Code Tag等，但很难预测确切的时刻或确切的模型。所以当面对新信息时，适应性如何让你做出更好的决策，而不是保持同样的计划。所以这种敏捷性非常重要。我认为另一个部分是，如何真正地进行第一性原理思考，推理下一步是什么？那又怎么样？我们如何投资新产品？我们如何向用户解释差异？所以我认为处于那个指数中的很多体验就是，把握节奏，理解你如何运作并做出更好的决策，然后应用第一性原理思考去做一些事情。”
“所以，沿着这个话题说，有趣的是，如果你回顾达里奥的所有预测，他就是说编码将在大约一年内百分之百解决之类的话。他一直谈论我们将用AI做所有的代码。我记得当时大家都说，‘不可能，这太复杂了。AI怎么可能真正擅长这种人类做的非常复杂的事情？不，这将在很长一段时间内由人类来做。’他完全正确。他还经常谈论的另一件事就是这个指数曲线，我们现在正处于其中。那就是他现在描述的方式。我们正处于指数曲线上。我记得不久前，新模型发布时，大家都说，‘好了，我们结束了。没有更多的上升空间了，它正趋于平稳，已经结束了，没有更多的增长空间了。’而现在则相反。现在我们身处其中，如果你考虑指数曲线，我们现在就在指数曲线的内部，这必然意味着每一个改进都是巨大的飞跃，因为我们正处于那个曲棍球棒部分。身处这个疯狂的历史时刻内部是什么感觉？AI进步如此之快，如此多的东西正在被解锁。那是什么感觉？人们应该如何为AI越来越多的进步加速做准备？我喜欢在团队中说的一个观点是，当互联网从新奇事物转变为每个人都能使用的东西时，我们大多数人还没有积极参与工作，感觉那只是人类正在经历的事情。我认为类比是有帮助的，所以类比一下就是，我认为有几件事，第一是适应性变得非常重要。我认为我们有评估、安全方面的安全测试红队、能力和产品方面的新原型产品如Cloud Code Tag等，但很难预测确切的时刻或确切的模型。所以当面对新信息时，适应性如何让你做出更好的决策，而不是保持同样的计划。所以这种敏捷性非常重要。我认为另一个部分是，如何真正地进行第一性原理思考，推理下一步是什么？那又怎么样？我们如何投资新产品？我们如何向用户解释差异？所以我认为处于那个指数中的很多体验就是，把握节奏，理解你如何运作并做出更好的决策，然后应用第一性原理思考去做一些事情。”
也许我们可以提出一个计划，原本我们预期几个月后才能实现，但现在模型已经能实际运作，并真正带给用户。这就是像协同工作技能标签这样的东西，你知道，这是一个非常
积极的自我强化循环。而且我认为很大一部分原因在于彼此信任，确保我们做出正确的决策，并带着大家一起前进。有些
团队可能比别人更快感受到这种指数级的进步。那么我们如何优雅地带领整个组织，以及不断成长的公司一起跟上呢？
>> 所以我听到的是，你几乎不知道每次模型发布后它能做什么。因此，关键是要在事情出现时保持适应性。正如你所说，产品本身必须跟上，
必须赶上可能性的步伐。再次强调，它虽然能做很多事情，但人们可能不知道如何使用，甚至无法做到。所以产品要让这一切变得简单，甚至只是告诉你这里有
你可以做的事情，这感觉像是很重要的一部分。你大概就是这个意思吧？
>> 我想是的。我认为最初的扩展定律论文中有一些非常有趣的图表，我想大家都很熟悉在更多计算和数据的情况下，损失（也就是所谓的
下一词预测的损失）会下降。所以这是一条非常平滑的线性曲线，模型随着规模的扩大而变得更加智能。实际上，那篇论文中同样有趣的是这些非常
不同的新兴能力图。例如，随着数据的增加和计算量的提升，你会看到这些不连续的新兴能力跳跃出现。所以模型从
无法计算1+1，到能够可靠地计算。这些新兴能力，这种某种程度上的不可预测性，并不一定是每个人都知道确切的时刻，你需要评估指标才能
评估，这实际上一直是这项技术运作的一部分，也正是让安全变得更加困难的原因，因为除非你有评估工具，除非你有测试系统，否则这些跳跃可能真的会
发生，而你却不知道。这太有趣了，你可能开发了一个AI大脑，它能做一些你甚至没意识到的事情，所以工作的部分就是去发现‘哇，我们刚刚在
这方面变得很厉害，我们能做些什么呢？’
>> 我觉得有产品过剩和用户过剩，用我们产品经理的话来说，即使在今天的模型上，我认为在现有的Opus版本上还有很多可以探索的，当然还有
像Fable这样的例子，比如temple，这种发现实际上是Anthropic早期基因的一部分，我认为它也将继续成为我们在产品、实验室和整个研究中的一大运作方式。这让我
想到了YC总裁Gary Tan一直在谈论的事情，我不知道他的头衔是不是这个。他有一个有趣的观点，如果你现在愿意每年花10万美元在token上，你就生活在
2028年人们的生活方式，因为到那时它会变得很便宜，每个人都能这样工作。但如果你现在有这种提前体验未来的机会，那就尽情在token上挥霍吧。所以有一个巨大的
机会让人们了解未来的样子，并且更快地构建东西。你对这个想法和‘token最大化’的价值有什么看法？是的，我认为我更多是从产品角度来看。这几乎就像
token花费是输入，真正的输出是你所描述的实验，如果我们将目标围绕实验来设定，我觉得这可能是一个更好的结果框架，因此
可能有不同的方式来实现那个结果。我要说，在内部，一些最有创意的思考者，最好的原型设计师，确实花了很多时间与Claude互动，使用每一个新版本的研究模型。所以确实有
一些东西，你必须使用模型才能提出好主意，然后更好的主意，甚至更棒的主意，没有替代品。在技术快速发展的時候，如果不接触技术，很难想出完美的策略。
同时，我认为还有其他事情可以做，比如我们经常在Anthropic内部公开工作。早期我们产品表面还不多的时候，
有一个Slack频道，几乎整个公司的人都在测试早期版本的Claude，尝试不同的用例。人们没有称其为用例，但你可能会让它编辑一篇文章，或者
想出合适的邮件发送方式。这些都是不同的用例，但我们都在公开环境工作。然后你会看到神奇的事情，不同的用户或不同的团队成员提出一个想法，
然后其他人尝试该想法的不同变体，然后在大约10次请求之内，就会出现某种神奇的东西，或者可能是一个新的用例。我认为这其中有很多价值，不仅仅在于个人独自摸索。
他们自己如何使用这项技术。我觉得我们在做实验的时候，其实可以更多地促进这种集体发现。实验并不总是一个人的事。
这太有趣了。是的。这种想法，就是我们不确定它有什么能力，或者我们能拿它做什么，这需要大家不断摸索，尝试各种方法，听听别人在尝试什么，来搞清楚
可能实现什么。这是一种有趣的技术，或者就是，哦，我发现它能做这个，那你能用它来做什么呢？
我觉得从宏观主题来看，我们知道这些模型能写很好的文章，或者能写长篇内容，但具体到用户的痛点，你能真正用它解决什么问题，并把它带到用户层面，让人们能够使用，
这更多是基于探索或实验的。
顺着这个话题，你负责实验室团队的产品，这非常酷。我们曾邀请Ben man和Mike Griger上播客，他们现在都在实验室工作，谈论实验室。实验室是什么？实验室产出了什么？很多人
都听说过这些，它们是如何运作的，使得他们能在Anthropic核心产品团队之外创造出如此创新的想法？实验室的论点在很多方面是识别并拉动那些不在核心路线图中的不连续的大赌注的线索，
弄清楚那里是否有价值，以及那个价值的10倍、100倍、1000倍是什么。所以举个例子，比如Cloud Code，我想
我听说过[笑声]像Cloud Code，还有Skills，最近还有Cloud Design MCP。我们在团队内部真正强调的是，尤其是现在，有太多东西可以构建，
那么，做一个不连续的赌注意味着什么？我认为我们今年采取的一个方法是，你可以对主题或领域持有非常坚定的观点，但对具体的原型则持有较弱的观点。
所以，有一种实验文化。有很多自下而上的尝试，团队里的工程师非常自主，自己驱动去测试不同的想法，有时候我们有论点，但可能还不行，所以我们
可能会在一到两个模型代际之后重新审视它。所以，这些原型实际上最终帮助我们学习，即使它们不会立即带来什么产品，这也是有价值的。所以我
我觉得这样一来，实验室的孵化和章程就能真正加速，让Anthropic能看到更远的拐角。有趣的是，在Anthropic这个已经如此创新的公司内部再设立实验室，这想法本身就很有意思。
充满创造力，你知道，就是疯狂地推出产品，在Anthropic内部仍然有一个实验室团队是有价值的。是什么让实验室运作得这么好，因为你列举了所有这些产品，让我们看看还有什么
Anthropic已经推出了什么，感觉几乎所有最大的成功都在这里。我相信还有很多我现在没想到的。在一个更大的公司里，创建一个成功的实验室的核心是什么？我认为
那种团队文化，我觉得和Anthropic的整体文化很相似，团队文化是非常宝贵的。我认为Ben设定了令人难以置信的愿景，推动人们去思考10倍、100倍的想法，你知道我们的团队是
实验室里的小组规模很小。有时候这些想法是从一个工程师开始的，对吧？而且我觉得有时候，当非常大的团队去追求模糊的大想法时，实际上会因为这个而被拖慢。所以我觉得这是
文化。我觉得我们其实也在筛选那些真正想做从零到一实验的人，这并不容易。有很多赌注我们最终会放弃或者关闭。而且也许，你知道，我们会在未来的某个时候重新审视它们。
未来。但这很难。当你全身心投入，像创始人一样为某个赌注全力以赴，而它却还没成功时，这真的很难。所以我觉得，这其实是在筛选那种真正对从零到一充满热情、执着的人。
那种对从零到一充满热情和深度投入的人。
所以你负责研究团队的产品。你和Anthropic的研究员一起工作。很多人大概知道研究是什么，研究员做什么，但我觉得大家其实并不完全了解这些。
这些在AI实验室里非常宝贵的人才。我是这么理解的，我想帮大家理解，也帮我自己理解——研究员整天到底在做什么？我猜他们会有个假设，关于怎么改进模型。
然后去找数据，调算法，检查训练方式，测试效果，不断迭代，持续寻找改进模型的方法。大概是这样吗？也帮我们理解一下研究员整天都在干啥？
研究员整天都在做什么？
这确实，我觉得这可能是比较日常的部分。但我想说，在Anthropic这样的研究机构，研究员还有一个更宏观的未来愿景。比如，像……
呃，我觉得甚至在创办公司之初，研究人员就在讨论怎么让Claude用电脑，怎么让AI去操作屏幕，对吧。所以其实有很多非常创始人精神的能量，我就是这么形容的。
在研究人员中，或者说真正大胆且有抱负的研究人员中，就有很多这样的能量，我们在Anthropic就有很多这样的人。所以对于这项技术能走向何方，有一层愿景，然后我想在另一个层面，也就是反馈循环的另一端，既然现在这项技术或Claude已经交到用户手中，
我们就得思考如何让它今天变得更好，所以这既关乎中长期，也需要很多精力去思考未来的视角，同时也要在眼前和短期内找到可以改进的地方。
所以我觉得你描述得很好，就是如何对不同版本的Claude进行迭代改进。我的团队和研究人员合作的方式，就是非常紧密地融入那些循环，
特别是在对用户影响很大的领域，比如视觉、电脑使用、编程、代理编程、工具使用、测试时计算，这些直接影响用户体验的方面，然后找出方法来把用户反馈，
用一种研究人员能理解、能操作的方式呈现出来。我觉得第二部分其实是工作的重要部分，有时也是难点。
比如，我们可能会在cla.ai上收到反馈说Claude产生了幻觉，这很模糊。如果你拿给研究员说“请修复Claude的幻觉”，这不太可操作。所以团队的一部分工作就是理解，
好的，用户为什么给出那样的反馈，这是经过用户同意的。所以我们看看，Claude在那时应该调用什么工具，或者根据它现有的知识，
或者它调用了正确的工具，查看了正确的文档，但看错了事实。在第一种情况下，那是工具使用的失败；第二种情况下，可能是搜索或知识整合的失败，
再或者可能和一致性有关。所以要把这种细节带给研究人员，去判断这是不是足够大的问题，设计评估方法来描述我们如何改进，
这些就是可操作性的层次，也是研究人员的日常语言。所以我们尽量密切关注如何以可操作的方式，把用户反馈带到核心模型训练和研究开发循环中。
我之前在和别人聊天时说到，感觉现在做AI研究是很有前途的领域，如果你想在生活中取得成功的话。那么，从你的角度看，一个真正成功的研究人员需要具备哪些素质呢？
你知道，不是每个人都能进入这个领域，不是每个人的思维方式都适合，但假如有人说‘我想探索这个职业道路’，根据你的观察，要怎样才能走到那一步呢？
研究人员通常是做研究的，或者和研究人员一起工作的产品经理，或者两者兼顾。
我们就说两者吧，但研究人员，比如和研究人员一起工作的产品经理也会非常成功。但感觉每家公司都在试图挖走所有顶尖研究人员，所以我知道你……
你不是AI研究人员，但就你所见，要在这条职业道路上取得成功，需要什么呢？
是的，我认为Anthropic很多最成功的研究人员和研究领导，都是对问题有很强第一性原理思考的人。他们能把问题推理得很透彻，而且对自己的研究领域充满热情。
他们对研究领域有大胆的设想，而且真正贴近细节。所以我们的领导、首席科学家、负责微调和强化学习的人，实际上非常接近训练过程。
他们会看训练运行的评估，查看底层数据。所以真正保持贴近，并乐于处理细节，我觉得这是优秀研究人员的标志，也是培养品味的表现。
我认为另一个方面是，他们有能力长期思考大问题，并且非常有雄心，对吧？就像Dario那样，我们可以改变软件工程，而且我认为……
朝着那个方向走，你会学到很多，你必须要有远大目标，在很多方面都要大胆设想，我认为这样才能成为成功的研究人员。
我喜欢这个梗，‘要更有野心’现在经常被提起，但做起来很难。说很容易，但真正要有多大格局，这就是AI现在解锁的东西。要更有野心。
是的。
我认为要思考一两次，然后确定方向，在具体方法上可以灵活一些，但对领域要执着。这是我们自问的一个问题，但技术是……
发展如此之快，你如何确保正在构建的东西真正具有前瞻性和兼容性？这其实也是核心产品开发循环中应该考虑得更长远的一部分。我经常问团队的一个问题是
或者当我思考产品开发时，假设Claude 8问世，用户行为会发生什么变化，这对今天的开发意味着什么？它是否会
与那种体验向前兼容，对吧？所以，我认为雄心壮志很宽泛，我们需要以某种方式来描述和界定它。
而且，一切都朝着一个连贯合理的方向发展，而不是仅仅朝着一个完全不同的方向去雄心勃勃。说到雄心和Claude 8，Fable Mythos最近似乎达到了一个新的临界点。过去，你有一个很棒的模型，发布就行了，大家好，Opus 45出来了，每个人都能用。而Mythos走了完全不同的路线，它被封锁了，
受到了很多审查和关注，担心它能做什么。所有公司都必须确保它不会入侵他们的系统。感觉现在每个模型，随着它们不断进步，都会
（译文省略）
现在审查更严格了，对谁能用也有更多限制，这感觉是件大事。你对此怎么看？这会怎么改变你们的运作方式？
政策啊、出口管制那边，我可能就留给专门负责的同事去处理了。我觉得产品这块，还有我们内部怎么用这些模型，就像你提到的，随着前沿模型越来越厉害，
安全措施、红队测试、发布前的流程，这些也得赶紧跟着变，适应新情况。举个例子，以前没有这些前沿模型的时候，我们并没有那么强的后备交互界面，
或者后备系统，因为我们的目标就是要确保这技术带来的好处是不对称的，同时把负面影响或者严重风险降到最低。所以我们后来就建了后备系统，
这样即使用户用不了最强的模型，比如Opus 4，他们还是能得到很好的回答。所以我觉得，在我们改进安全系统的同时，怎么继续做出好的用户体验，这是个问题。我觉得两边都还有改进空间。
所以接下来几周、几个月，你们会看到我们在模型安全包上不断推陈出新，让它越来越好。
真正有趣且出人意料的是，这为Anthropic创造了一个极其有利的优势，你们能最先接触到最新成果，而每个实验室都会不断进步，这就在实验室内部形成了不公平的优势，能使用别人暂时无法触及的最佳资源。
你更希望所有人都能用上，所以这个新的反馈循环即将开启，非常有趣。
届时，只有特定公司才能使用如此先进的模型，这将是全新的、未曾预料的影响，算是这些限制的第二层效应吧。
我们的目标是尽可能包容地开发这些系统和模型。我们的目标是不让这种情况发生，保持通用、普及，让技术更易获取。这算是我们最优先的事项之一。
目前，我们正努力减少这种情况的出现。
确实，这么说有道理。我想象你们会希望有尽可能多的用户使用这个产品。本期节目由Mercury赞助，一家颠覆性的银行，深受超过30万创业者的喜爱，现在更是如此。
命令。我是Mercury的客户超过6年了。我从来没有想过离开。Mercury基本上就是当银行业由产品人员而不是银行家来构建时会发生的事情。他们让发送发票、转账、为团队成员设置虚拟卡变得如此容易，我敢说有趣。
你的银行有API、终端原生CLI或AI就绪的MCP服务器吗？我不觉得。而且就在最近，他们推出了Command，一个直接内置在Mercury中的对话界面，充当你的财务操作员。
我一直在用Command来转账，弄清楚我在哪些类别上花费最多，分析我的现金流，就在今天我还用它来
想知道过去一年我从某个赞助商那里赚了多少。我就问，[音乐]“过去一年我从X那里赚了多少？”10秒后，答案就有了。这简直太酷了。访问mercury.com
了解更多信息，几分钟内在线申请。Mercury是一家金融科技公司，不是FDIC保险公司。银行服务由Choice Financial Group和Column NA成员FDIC提供。我想谈谈产品
角色如何变化，以及在这个新世界里谁表现得好，既然AI现在已经成为我们生活如此核心的一部分。当你招聘产品经理、产品人员时，当你观察那些在今天世界里表现出色的人时，你注意到哪些方面？
你最看重什么？你更看重什么？哪些方面趋势上升，你觉得重要，哪些方面又在下降？实际上，在我团队里，我们的招聘流程已经三年没变了，嗯。
所以我们寻找的特质，以及如何评估像产品经理这样的通才，比如研究型产品经理，其实一直是一样的。我认为这些特质中，第一点是第一性原理思维。
这实际上不是像你在消费产品或B2B SaaS中那样进行模式匹配，而是真正弄清楚在当下这个时刻，对于这个用户群体，利用这项技术，什么才是用户价值。
有没有一个例子能说明什么是第一性原理思维？很多人听到这个词，都会说“我知道，我很擅长这个”。但真正展现这种思维的例子是什么呢？
我觉得一个例子是，你可能会认为产品经理的职责是拥有产品策略和交付用户价值，但我的团队，比如研究产品经理，日常是通过撰写PRD或产品愿景文档来体现这一点的。
而对于研究产品经理来说，推动用户价值的方式是找到正确的用户反馈和评估标准，对吧？这些可以具体化为用户需求。我们确实会写一些产品文档和PRD，但我们的团队有一句话：
“评估是新的PRD”。因为要交付用户价值，不是靠过去一二十年人们写的那些文档，而是一种新的工作方式。所以第一点就是...
我主要的想法是，要搞清楚为了实现目标我应该做什么，而不是做了一堆活动然后继续下去。
所以这里的想法是，以前是有一个想法，写个PRD，跟人讨论，对齐计划，设计，开发，上线，看效果，再迭代。现在我听到的是，比如有一些反馈，关于哪里出了问题或者有机会。
第一步就是评估，用评估来定义工作内容，而不是用PRD。
也许第一步是理解用户的痛点。而且接触用户痛点的方式也不同了，对吧？以前我们可能做用户访谈，我觉得如果深入下去，你可以让用户带你走一遍他们的流程，就像看像素一样。现在，你得像关注像素一样关注token。所以我们团队有一项工作就是阅读文本记录，理解失败轨迹。
嗯，那些失败的轨迹，要深入分析，看看是不是幻觉？还是Claude过度自信了？所以失败的主题其实有很多细微差别，然后这让你能写出一个描述。
这个描述就可以指导下一步的工作，而不是仅仅根据已有的活动来行动。
比如对那种痛点的持续描述。那基本上可以成为一个新的评估，而且这个评估是在分布内的，对吧？它既要捕捉到那些失败的情况，也要捕捉到那些本不应该失败的地方。
然后把这个反馈带回给研究团队，这样我们就能做出改进，并真正衡量质量——比如当我们有Opus 5.5时，这个领域是否在进步？Claude现在能不能准确地识别文档中的正确位置，并提炼出正确的综合内容？
所以说，关键在于可操作性，缩短与可操作性之间的距离，这样我们的利益相关者和合作团队，比如研究人员，就能采取行动。
>> 有没有这样的例子，你发现了一个问题或机会，然后写了评估？在大多数情况下，评估是什么样的？当人们想象一个评估时，他们会想到什么？
>> 我们实际上在Anthropic内部开创了这个概念。所以早期的例子之一是，早期的云模型在遵循特定模式方面表现不佳，比如像输出JSON这样的东西，而现在这对Claude能否成为一个好的代理来说至关重要。
对吧？如果你不能输出特定格式，你就不知道如何访问API，不能调用工具等等。所以最初端到端的反馈是，我听到关于……你知道的……的反馈。
克劳德刚发布的时候，它在遵循指令方面表现不佳。于是我们深入用户，询问他们所谓克劳德不擅长遵循指令具体指什么？请告诉我这种情况发生的场景，确切地说
比如具体是哪一段？你问了什么？克劳德回答了什么？就是这样细致入微。我发现早期大约80%的用户反馈的这个问题，实际上是克劳德没有生成正确的JSON。
于是我们就开始着手，先收集30到40个克劳德出错的例子。这些例子就成了我们的评估集。基本上就是提示词和响应，如果它没有按照
你期望的正确答案来回应，那就说明这个评估集很有价值，因为它一直能指出痛点。然后我们把它加入评估库。当我们有了新版本的克劳德时，我们
就会运行这个评估集来检查。我觉得现在这个准确率已经达到了100%或者99.9%。所以这不再是痛点。但在早期，我们吸取用户反馈，弄清楚他们真正的意思，我们能否
复现这个问题，它是否是持续性的，是否是重大问题。然后想办法把它标准化，让研究人员能够使用。基本上，我们现在所处的世界，就是产品经理的测试驱动开发。
也就是说你先写测试。所以这就是现在Anthropic产品经理工作的核心部分吗？写测试？
我觉得也是。我还跟其他Piana公司的人聊过，而且我觉得这技能面会越来越广，因为我们做的很多产品，都是模型加上各种框架，再加上为特定用户群定制的场景。
所以，有评估系统不只是对搞模型的人有用，对整个产品团队来说，也是提升用户体验的关键，因为没法改进连测量都测不了的东西。
而且这过程很多时候还是凭感觉，靠判断，所以你必须贴近细节。
而且这玩意儿还很随机，这是个大问题——它每次给的答案可能都不一样。所以你得概括着描述，没法要求一字不差。这让产品开发的方式，真的开始变了。
评估系统是其中一大块。你们现在还写PRD（产品需求文档）吗？还是一页纸把问题说清楚，还是直接打？你摇头了，是不是不用了？
我们还是会做的。我觉得，遇到定义得很清楚的问题，评估系统几乎能当个速记用。但在其他情况下，PRD很有价值，它是把那需求讲清楚的好工具。
一大群人围绕着一套关于体验和设定目标的事实来源达成一致。所以当我们确实有一个模型时，实际上对于我们每个模型，我们确实有一个PRD，这不一定是为了我们的研究人员，更多是为了我们不断增长的产品
界面，为了我们的工程团队，为了我们的利益相关者，比如法律和安全部门和其他人，作为我们想达成目标的一个事实来源，这样一大群人就能朝着同一个方向划船。
另一个我认为PRD有价值的地方是在更模糊的问题和机会上，对吧，所以如果我们还没有发布像计算机使用这样的东西，我们不一定有一套用户特定的痛点
总是如此，我觉得PRD中的产品愿景部分有价值，去探索即使技术还没有准备好为所有人服务，你如何让它为某些群体工作得好。这样你可以探索价值，你可以
实际上为某个用户群体带来一些连贯的东西。所以我们确实有PRD。嗯，我认为应用方式现在有点不同了。
好的，这太棒了。我刚刚有一个安德鲁，他是OpenAI的Codex应用负责人，他和你观点一致。PRD没有死。对于特定的项目和想法仍然非常有用。好的，我们已经关闭了
关于纯粹性的讨论已经结束，但这一话题仍在继续。好的，我们一直在讨论产品人员正在涌现出哪些技能。除了这些，你发现对于在这个新AI世界中表现出色的人们，还有哪些常见的模式发生了变化？
对于产品经理和产品团队中的其他人来说，还有什么其他的变化？你是否觉得有什么需要调整的地方，或者你会更关注哪些特质？
我想，特别是对于处于职业生涯中期或更多处于管理职位，比如产品领导角色的人，我强烈认为，要成为善于管理团队和产品经理并与之合作的人，
你自己必须非常亲力亲为，不仅要花时间摆弄技术，还要真正用这项技术交付产品，并且要深入细节，与你的产品经理、工程师和团队一起抠每一个token。
因此，即使是我招聘的有丰富产品经验的人，他们的入职计划也与早期职业新手完全相同，重点是理解用户、阅读同意后的用户反馈，以及与客户交谈。
我认为，能够理解如何处理这些问题，知道什么是好的表现，并且通过非常亲力亲为的方式发展这种能力，这一点很重要。对于某人来说，
如果他们没有亲身经历过构建过程，就不一定容易同意或看到什么是好的或伟大的AI产品或功能。所以，我确实强烈认为，如果你是一名经理，
你必须亲力亲为，你必须花一部分时间实际交付产品，你必须设身处地为你的团队着想。我总是努力腾出一部分时间，当有模型时，亲自负责一两个工作流，
以保持我的理论思维，保持我对模型如何发展、改进速度有多快的感知，这样我才能帮助团队做出更好的决策。
所以我听到的是，无论你在公司的层级中处于什么位置，如果你自己不构建，如果你不亲自与Claude对话、与Codex对话、去构建东西，你就不会成功。
而且你应该享受与这项技术合作的乐趣。我认为这是另一部分。我认为无论层级如何，最成功的人是那些热爱与AI合作、积极探索、
不断实验，并抽出时间不仅进行实验，而且亲力亲为地端到端交付，获取用户反馈，这应该是每个人的基本要求。
我完全明白你的意思。就像我坐在我的订阅通讯和这个播客里谈论这些，听起来很不错。但实际上每次我自己构建东西，摆弄各种小细节时，才真正体会到这个道理。
看到这些项目的时候，你心里会想，哦，我明白怎么回事了。然后你会得到更多的体验，很难准确描述你实际和模型一起工作、构建东西时的感受，但就像
进入了一个全新的世界，你会想，哦，我懂了，这就是他们说的计算机使用，这就是他们提到的局限性，以及这种用户体验上的问题。
是的。
所以，是的，就像你说的，你提出了一个很有趣的观点，就是你必须从中找到乐趣，这对很多人来说并不容易，因为他们是被迫使用AI，或者他们根本不知道拿它做什么。
对于有些人来说，他们觉得，我不知道，这太烦人了，我不得不做这个。我不明白这有什么好的，我讨厌这玩意儿，为什么我要和它一起工作？变化太快了，我都累了。那么，有什么建议
能帮助人们找到这种工作中的乐趣呢？我想重申我之前说过的一点，那就是实验不是一个人的事。就像我觉得，在我触及了
几乎所有版本的研究模型，以及到目前为止二十个版本的Claude生产模型之后，我觉得乐趣的一部分来自于看到别人发现新的使用案例。所以，一个想法可能是和一个很兴奋的人结对，
在你关心的一个使用案例上一起探索，而不是自己琢磨出完美的使用案例，因为那可能感觉像工作。和他人一起工作很多时候会带来快乐。
我们还能做些什么来带动其他人呢？这很像，很多时候我们内部会有个充满好奇心的人，然后他们分享一个新原型的想法，这就会吸引更多
人，他们就会想，哦，我不知道这个现在能和Claude一起用。所以这里有一些良性的循环，以及一些方法，来保持这种技术带来的乐趣。
你说得太对了。我想这也是为什么Twitter对很多人来说很有用，因为你看到别人分享他们做过的事情，
然后它会激发你自己的小点子，同时分享你做过的东西也很有趣。
所以这真的是个好建议，就是找一些其他人一起玩，寻找使用案例。我也常听到人说，找一个你想在生活或工作中解决的问题，然后打开Claude
代码，告诉它你想做什么，你会发现即使只是模糊地知道问题，你也能走得很远。是的，我想难点在于有太多不同的事情可以尝试。
是的。
所以你要么专注于与人配对，和那些对这技术充满热情的人一起工作，要么找一些你能立即找到价值的事情。无论选哪个，
这些都能让你深入，而不是对太多的事情浅尝辄止。我觉得很难跟上外面那些原型或产品的数量，所以我的方法是，选择一两个深入进去。
我自己也是这样。你说的太有意思了，因为正是如此。我们刚刚做了一项调查，是我和同事诺姆一起做的，问我的读者他们对现在科技界的情况，
以及AI的感受，其中一个最有趣的发现是，幸福感恰恰就像你说的，深入一两件事，而不是尝试一大堆小事情。找到几件事真的
做好，然后深入进去，因为很多人感到快乐的时候，是他们终于解锁了一种方式，让AI真正改善他们的生活，而不是只是那些乱七八糟、半途而废的东西。
是的，这就像如何从仅仅勾选一个复选框开始？我们作为产品人，这其实是一种对时间和精力的产品优先级排序。如果目标是在实验中寻找乐趣，那么
你需要哪些输入呢？是的，我觉得Anthropic的秘诀就在于文化、工作的自下而上的性质，以及这种公开实验的态度。
通过这种方式，很重要的是如何带动其他人。我觉得最终这会很有价值。是的，我从各个实验室都听到过这样的话，没人确切知道这些要怎么用，
很多就是早点发布，看看人们怎么用，看看有什么可能，然后用这些信息来构建真正的产品并引领潮流。
是的，是的。
我很好奇，关于寻找AI帮助你在工作和生活中提效这个话题，作为产品经理，你最近有没有用Claude做些有趣的事？我觉得有很多可能性。
比如fable和tag这类工具。tag还在很早期的阶段，我觉得这涉及到一种不同的工作方式——让智能体去干活，然后把成果带回来给你。
有一个领域虽然不是最新的，但我经常跟团队提，也觉得我们可以在AI使用上做得更多，就是如何用它来进行更好的沟通，成为更好的管理者。
我觉得这不仅仅是提升我们构建产品的智商，我还经常用它来准备如何进行更好的对话，尤其是在关键对话的当下。
我特别喜欢那本书（《关键对话》），所以实际上我有一个技能，帮助我判断在特定情况下，我的沟通细节是否恰当，这真的让我成为更好的管理者，更好地支持团队。
所以，对于团队里的管理者，我一直在分享这个——如何用Claude让你成为更好的教练。
因为有时候很难找到完美的措辞，而模型有很多完美的词句。
我觉得这确实能从情感（EQ）角度提升我们，而不仅仅是智商。哇，这里面有好多有趣的东西。让我理解一下你在做什么。你构建了一个技能。
就像Claude构建一个技能，从《关键对话》这本书中汲取经验——它足够了解这本书，你甚至不需要提供内容。然后你用那个技能和Claude对话，比如‘嘿，我要跟同事进行一场很难的对话’。
这场对话即将到来。
给我一些建议，怎么去处理。
对，这就像个性化的教练，教你如何……我们整天都在频繁切换上下文，有Claude帮我配对，帮我……有时候我可能不会采用Claude的建议。
但最终它对于头脑风暴非常有帮助，比如‘我这样考虑反应对吗？’‘我怎样才能更快地深入？’‘更快建立信任？’‘更直接？’
对，没错。
哇，我有很多问题。这太有趣了。首先，有人担心人们会开始像AI那样写作，因为他们跟AI聊得太多了，就会变成‘戴安，不是这个，是那个’。
我知道你不会那样，但这是人们的担忧。我想问一下，你担心这个吗？就是人们说的‘脑腐’或‘萎缩’。
我们现在太依赖AI了，不再学习和思考，而且你那么接近AI，经常与它融合。
对我来说，很多思考过程和写作过程是紧密相连的。所以我觉得有些方式我用Claude来增强思考。但我想确保——也许这就是你描述的——Claude不会接管我所有的思考。
所以我认为取决于情况，取决于我在某个情况下想保留多少个人判断。我可能先有自己的观点，然后和Claude一起推敲。
确保我保持自己的感觉和语调。然后也有其他事情，比如更新——我们有月度业务评审，那些情况下，
我更希望它是标准的，更希望它把信息清晰地提炼出来，而且我有个技能，我们正在改进那个技能。
但我想达到的状态是，月度业务评审的写作价值可能比思考价值低得多，所以我怎么才能把那个部分完全交给Claude，而我更多是审核和验证信息。
所以我觉得这取决于你用Claude做什么，你想传达什么，以及是否在把更多事情委托给Claude时有不对称的价值。
我还听到的第一个建议很棒，就是先思考，有自己的观点，然后把Claude当作一个陪练伙伴，来发展观点、挑战观点。
对，没错。我觉得这里我们的对齐研究和安全研究很有用，因为你不想让AI只是一味同意你，对吧？你想要的是这项技术能……
实际上，它确实能提升和增长，帮助我们达成更好的结果。有时候，让Claude提出质疑反而让我更好。这很棒。就像同事一样，当我的想法还没有完全成型时，我希望有人能提出反对意见。
我想多听听这个。但我听说，当Ben man上播客时，他谈到了内置在Claude中的宪法，以及他们如何非直观地在安全和一致性上投入，就像你提到的，还有这部宪法。
这部宪法描述了Claude应该如何思考和运作，你可能会认为这会限制Claude的能力，让它变得不那么有趣和引人入胜。但恰恰相反。Claude是最有个性的，我经常听到这样的评价。
不断有人说，我更喜欢和Claude聊天，就像Open Claw，它最初是建立在Claude之上的，但后来人们被迫换掉，我们就不深入了，他们被迫更换后说，这太糟糕了，这不是我习惯对话的对象。
所以，我觉得这是个非常有趣的观点，我想确保我们花点时间讨论一下。为什么是这样？为什么专注于一致性和安全性，拥有明确的宪法，就能让Claude变得更好、更有趣呢？
还有，
为了让Claude尽可能聪明能干，它得能在关键时刻提出异议，然后给出是或否的建议，真正帮你得出更好的结论。所以，
我就用Claude来帮忙，比如我们在给Claude下一版定价时，这样做对不对？这有点自我指涉，但用研究版的Opus，让它自己想怎么定价，
最终能得出更好的结果就是我们的目标。所以，让AI不只是个助手，不只是个执行者，不只是被派活儿，而是要搞清楚它做的事情对不对。这其实很
关键，就是要知道什么时候该反驳。
对吧？这也就是知道什么时候该主动的一部分。主动性不是说你总是按计划去做事，而是知道什么时候该出新点子。所以，为了让Claude更有用，
总体的思路就是它得知道什么时候该提出异议。这是模型整体特质中的一个核心部分。
这太有意思了。有趣的是，它不那么顺从，这在很大程度上反而让它变得更好、更有用，因为我们需要这样。我遇到很多人说，
“嘿，AI告诉我我是对的。”但其实我希望它也能对别人这么说。
对，这又回到了我们之前关于思考的讨论，对吧？你怎么保护你的思考？
嗯，如果你有一个能作为思考伙伴的AI，思考伙伴不会只是同意你。它应该能给你补充，这样一天结束时，你会因为和Claude合作而拥有更好的想法。
这应该是终极目标，而不仅仅是让你的想法好10%。对，我喜欢这个说法，因为以前常说“十倍思维”。过去创始人激励人们的方式是“如果我们把这个做到十倍呢？”而我现在常听到的是，
“我们怎么能从这个想法做到千倍？”什么是最雄心勃勃的版本？我想回到我们刚才谈论关于不断和Claude对话时想到的一点。很明显，
当AI写了什么东西时，你还是能看出来。有趣的是，它是一个大型语言模型，你会以为它最擅长写作，但奇怪的是，没有哪个AI特别擅长写作，AI写的内容总是很明显。
你觉得我们会不会到达一个我们无法分辨这是AI写的的地步？
我认为这取决于你希望达到什么目标。如果你想知道，那评估标准是什么？实际上，我确实认为我们还可以做更多让Claude写得更好。实际上有很积极的努力，
在我的团队和研究方面，都在努力让Claude写得更好。总的来说，我觉得应该清楚一个想法是由你还是由我，比如Lenny或Dianne，来主导的。这真的取决于写作的目标是什么。
比如对于像月度业务回顾这样的东西，我其实希望从头到尾都由Claude来写。
而且显然，不要让它感觉像是人类写的。你提的这点很有意思：知道它是AI写的，而不是人类，对我们来说是不是更好？
对，但或许这更多是关乎可验证性，或者谁来验证的问题。
对，输出。对，对。就像是谁来签字确认。嗯，可能更少关注谁在写，而是谁在验证，谁来签字。这比谁在写更重要。
为什么你觉得AI不擅长写作？我猜它已经研究过人类所有最好的写作了。它已经找出了最好的写作方式。现在我们和它只是，写作的方式也就这么多。
所以我们只是认识到，好吧，这就是AI能做的。它有一些俗套。这是核心原因吗？还是有别的东西让它不能成为伟大的作家？讽刺的是，作为一个大语言模型，
你会觉得它肯定很擅长语言。
我觉得部分原因是我们需要更多投资于训练改进，让AI在写作等领域持续强大。嗯，我觉得这也像我们提到的，技术是参差不齐的。所以有时候当
模型擅长写作但不擅长代理行为时，我们的论点是，我们如何让模型更具代理性，或者调用正确的工具。现在这方面有所改进，那么这些其他领域实际上就成了新的短板。
所以我觉得我们正处于写作这样的时刻，我们确实需要专注于优先训练模型在这个领域变得出色，这对我们来说是一个非常活跃的领域，就像你提到的。
好的，我很高兴。而且，一旦AI变得如此出色，以至于我们都说“我不知道这是谁写的”，但正如你所说，有时我们实际上想知道这是AI写的。这真的很有趣。我
从没这么想过。另一个有趣的地方是，有个喜剧演员开玩笑说，我们在飞机上，Wi-Fi断了，我们就会说：“搞什么鬼？这飞机上Wi-Fi怎么不能用。这
太烂了。你怎么敢？”当你在空中像鸟一样飞行的铁管里时，你怎么还抱怨Wi-Fi不能用。你的观点是，我们取得了巨大的进步，拥有了巨大的力量，但我们不能解决所有问题。我们
不能让所有东西都完美运行。所以基本上AI写作不是优先事项，但现在感觉那里有了更多投资。
是的，我觉得语气和性格是优先事项。我认为技术的进步是一个持续的过程，所以我们看到代理行为有了飞跃或涌现，这是一个新的
常态，然后这些其他能力也需要继续改进。
而且我觉得一旦我们改进了，比如说写作、语气和性格，我们可能会说：
我们如何让Claude更主动？生产力是一个机会，这是人性，我们想让自己变得更好，我们想让这项技术变得更好。嗯，所以我觉得我们把它应用于
AI是正确的，我们应该让它变得更好。
我想问你几个问题，我经常问那些从事未来核心工作的人。一是你认为未来几年人脑在哪些方面会继续最有价值？我知道Anthropic的
使命和愿景是达到通用人工智能、超级智能。所以未来也许没有哪里，但在我们到达那里之前，在我们接近那个时间线时，你认为人脑在哪些方面会继续最有价值？
我们开始讨论让Claude和模型在判断力方面变得更好，特别是最近一年左右。我觉得判断力是一个方面，它积累了大量细微差别和经验，这些
系统没有像人类那样经历过那么多，所以我觉得来之不易的判断力是产品领导者以及总体来说继续至关重要的一个领域。AI能构建的东西太多了。
哪些是实验室应该构建的？很多都需要人类判断力，持久性，主动性，这些都是超越一般能力的行为和
特征，比如那些级别的人如何得到最佳解决方案，如何创造最佳体验。所以我觉得这些特质实际上是触觉特质，我认为它们将继续重要。嗯，
我觉得还有很多能力和专业知识也很重要。你知道，软件工程已经被AI彻底改变了。我觉得像生物学、生命科学这样的领域，这些都是
我们只是处于指数增长的起点，比如软件工程可能就已经在指数上了。我们处于其他一些领域的指数上。我们还没完全达到。所以我觉得你看到我们发布像Cloud
Science这样的产品，投资于这些领域，因为这些都是将技术带给社会并对社会产生积极影响的领域。所以我觉得那里还有很多工作要做。
另一个我想问的问题是，作为有孩子的人，你是怎么考虑鼓励他们学习什么的？或者你会不会在这个我们正在进入的神奇新世界里引导他们走向成功？
实际上我觉得很多特质和我们成长过程中学到的是一样的，比如
对学习的好奇心、坚持不懈、相信自己的内心声音、发展并相信自己的内心声音。我有一个四岁的孩子，一个八岁的孩子。我们有责任，我有责任帮助他们
培养他们的内心声音，无论是有主见还是敢于表态，对我来说，发展和鼓励这些，我觉得这种技能组合在将来很重要，还有
拥有他们自己的独特见解。
这太有意思了。这和你之前回答我关于如何避免“脑腐”和过度依赖AI时说的很相关，就是保持自己的观点和视角，不要过分依赖AI。
AI，以及你描述的培养孩子这种想法真的很重要。太有趣了，我喜欢这一切如何联系起来：判断力、坚持和拥有自己的观点。
是的。
对孩子和成人都适用。
是的。我们考虑一下对你的...
天哪。我一直在想的问题是，什么时候让他们接触AI这类东西。我有个三岁的孩子，所以还太早，但你知道，怎么引导他们进入这个
疯狂的世界？我最近参加了一个活动，很多家长都在讨论他们如何看待AI和孩子的关系。有个人提出了一个很有意思的方法，就是让他们使用非常早期的模型，这样
他们仍然需要努力，不会立刻得到所有答案。我觉得这很有趣。比如开源本地模型，
不稳定。
是的。
是的。好奇心是我一直提到的，Ben Man，但他的答案一直让我印象深刻，那就是好奇心，而且他也是蒙特梭利教育的忠实粉丝，这也是我们正在
鼓励孩子们去做的。所以有点道理。也许最后一个问题，沿着这个思路，实际上是Fiona Fun最近上播客时建议我问你的。你怎么保持精力充沛，
不会在这个疯狂的AI风暴中心感到疲惫，作为一位妈妈在Anthropic工作，你知道，我们正在看到研究进展。就像我们正经历前所未有的时期，在
Anthropic外部工作就已经很疯狂了。我甚至不知道内部是什么样子。你学到了什么关于避免职业倦怠、保持精力、保持理智的经验？在2024年，
我们全年发布了四个模型，或者说四个系列的模型，而今年仅第二季度我们就发布了超过这个数量的模型。[笑声] 我觉得自己很幸运，我们组建并建立的团队，包括
研究方面的利益相关者和我们的研究产品管理团队。我认为接近这一切的魔力之一在于它不是一个人的运动。有一种
极度的主人翁精神和团队协作，我认为有时候确实感觉像是高绩效运动，因为你处于非常关键的决策中。有关于用户和训练的新信息，你必须迅速提出建议、做出判断和决定，没有人能单靠自己持续做到这一点。
所以，我觉得真正有帮助的是拥有一个了不起的团队，他们互相照应，在发布前夜，即使不是该模型的核心负责人，也会熬夜帮助核心负责人，
审查博客文章、做编辑、提出更好的演示，成为彼此的得力助手。我认为如果你把所有变化都担在自己身上，很容易
你独自扛着一切，感觉自己孤立无援，好像所有事都得自己来。但我觉得Anthropic最神奇的一点，就是我们能发现那些互相帮助的机会，
然后真的更进一步，达到那种“心领神会”的境界。我们管这叫“进入蜂巢思维”。有篇文章专门讲过这个。我觉得这其中的一部分，就是让团队能够不断充电。不是说
我六月份刚休完假。不是说你可以休假，回来后事情就少了三倍。而是说，你可以放心休假，因为你知道团队能搞定该做的事，我们每个人
都能互相照应。所以我觉得这很重要。我个人也很幸运，我的伴侣非常支持我。这已经是我在AI领域工作的第六年了，从亚马逊到Anthropic，他看着我有多热爱
这项技术，以及它能带来什么，这真的很有帮助。从个人角度来说，也是如此。
——我很喜欢这些回答之间的关联。我听到的是，有其他人陪伴，与他人合作，依赖他人，在事情变得疯狂时互相帮助。这和你之前说的
如何在工作中找到快乐和乐趣的答案很相似。就是通过他人的启发，看看他们在做什么，
——一起合作。
——是的。有趣的是，最近Fiona来播客做客时，我问她软件工程界有什么变化，她指出现在更孤独了，因为我们在和智能体合作，
而不是和其他人。团队更小了，人们整天和一堆智能体对话。所以这提醒了我们，身边真实的其他人有多重要。
——我们被要求处理大事并做出决策，因为技术带来了更大的规模，对吧？我认为，如果有其他人能在某种程度上与你工作方式、你处理问题的方式产生共鸣——
也许不是每个细节都一致，但基本原则是什么？你做的假设是什么？这样他们就能为你提供支持，或者推动你的决策，让你的思维更敏锐。所以我觉得，
我们真的努力——我在组建团队、壮大团队、招聘时，会特别关注这一点：这个人是在乎自己的面子和构建庞大组织，还是他们在乎为Anthropic做贡献，
为团队的影响力做贡献，倾向于那些低调、以团队为导向的人。我觉得，这确实是可持续性的重要部分。
——是的，很多问题最终都归结到文化和招聘上。我听说了很多关于Anthropic为什么能如此快速前进的原因。我记得那个月每天都有新东西发布，
就像有一个发布日历，人们都在讨论这怎么可能。我听到很多是因为大家都对使命和价值观高度一致，这让大家能迅速做出决策。在我们进入
激动人心的快问快答环节之前，Dan，你还有什么想分享的吗？还有什么想补充的吗？或者想再强调一下我们聊过的内容吗？
——这其实很有趣，因为我觉得你的问题让我对自己这些思考的连接方式更加清晰了。我是你的真人版Claude。我真的很想传达的
一件事，或者说希望大家带走的，是工作方式上的一个要点，还有就是要认识到，这其中有大量的成长和变化，以及使用这项技术的乐趣。如果你此刻觉得
没有那么多最初的快乐了，那就想办法找到那些仍然充满热情的人，如果这是你感兴趣的领域，并且你想投入其中。我认为发展技能，以各种方式更新技能，比如
从第一性原理的角度思考你要解决什么问题。我想，虽然你没问我这个，但社区里确实有个疑问：当模型如此强大，工程师们积极参与时，我们还需要产品经理吗？
我认为，那些以用户为中心，深入理解用户想要达成什么目标，并将其以可操作的方式提炼出来，然后坚持不懈地做下去的人——
在我看来，这就是产品人员的核心。我实际上认为我们需要更多这样的人。我们变得非常技术驱动，但要让它产生影响力，你必须深入钻研，充满好奇心，而且要非常
亲力亲为。这些都是我认为帮助Anthropic在产品开发和模型开发方面取得成功的特质，也是文化的一部分。希望这对其他人也有价值。
——太棒了。真是个鼓舞人心的结尾。我的天。是的。这也是我长期以来一直在说的，现在构建东西很容易，难的是，正如你所说，我们该构建什么，以及我们构建的东西是不是
已经构建了正确、优秀、值得投入的东西，在我看来，这正是产品经理所做的，也是他们擅长的。
是的，是的，是的。而且这涉及到用户的细节。
是的。同理心。好的。太棒了。产品经理会成功的。好的。PRD没有死。[笑声]这里有各种各种重要的教训。嗯，Dan，我们到了非常激动人心的快速问答环节。我有五个问题要问你。准备好了吗？
准备好了。
第一个问题。你发现自己最常推荐给别人两三本书是什么？
一本是个人方面的，我非常喜欢《如何养育成年人》。我是一位母亲。我经常思考我想给孩子们灌输什么。那本书在描述我们不是在养育孩子，而是在养育成年人方面非常有帮助。
所以，这个框架是什么意思？我们想培养、磨练和培养孩子的哪些特质？呃，最近我在Audible上听的另一本书是
Eric Reese的《不可腐蚀》。
不可腐蚀，不可腐蚀，是的，是的。
是的。他最近是播客嘉宾。
嗯，是的。我觉得如何建立伟大公司的问题很重要。我个人对如何让优秀团队和伟大公司走得更远非常着迷。看到他对这个问题的框架和重新框架非常有趣。
我喜欢一些关于围绕文化设定指标的的例子。如果你不能，如果你只衡量收入，那就是你的前进方式，但如果你有
其他更好的指标，那实际上是维持你所关心价值观的方式。我一直在尝试思考如何将其落实到团队层面，比如我们如何更好地表达我们的规范，很多我们在团队里讨论的事情。
所以我觉得[哼]那也是一本很好的读物。
这就对了。呃，那将是你们大家的下一本必读书，当你们听这个的时候，Eric Greece那一集。
真是好一集。是的。
他的书也刚出版。《不可腐蚀》。
是的。
我觉得它好像是《纽约时报》畅销书。实际上它卖得非常好，我很高兴看到这一点。
是的，没错。
下一个问题。你最近喜欢看的电影或电视节目是什么？大多数Anthropic的人都没时间看东西，但我很好奇你有没有什么答案。我会说，上个月休假的时候，我确实去
狂刷了亚马逊Prime上的《辐射》。那其实我挺喜欢的，嗯，有点像，你听说过吗？
是的，是的，它是基于电子游戏的。
是的，它是基于电子游戏的。我认为它真的很有趣，很机智，很幽默，又超级注重动作。所以强烈推荐。
好的，下一个问题。你最近有没有发现特别喜欢的产品？
我确实觉得，从产品体验的角度来看，Claw Tag很有意思。实际上，在Anthropic内部我们有不同版本的这个东西，我觉得它真的非常非常强大。
是啊，感觉有些人会觉得这有什么大不了的？但是Anthropic的所有人都对它赞不绝口，这让我觉得这里肯定有重要的事情发生。我正试着把它用在我的付费订阅者社区里。
那会多酷啊？
是啊。
对啊，我在琢磨当它不是一个公司，而是一群互不相识的人时，它该怎么运作。我们正在尝试。好了，还有两个问题。你最喜欢的人生格言是什么，在工作或生活中经常让你想起的？
哦，其实我人生的前十年是由祖父母带大的，我的父母是来美国读大学和研究生的移民。
哇。我的祖父总是说，“无论你走多远，总还有更高的层次，”这个说法我觉得挺贴切，挺深刻地描述了他的人生哲学。但每当我们遇到新的或前所未有的事情时，我就会想起这句话。
今年上半年确实很多事情都是这样，有很多新的东西我们在学。我在学习，所以感觉就像
总有另一座山，另一个机会
不够好，我们要更上一层楼
我们要做得更大。这让我想起另一个嘉宾在他播客里说过的话：这是最正常的时候了，以后只会变得更奇怪更疯狂。
是的，是的，我们很好。好了，最后一个问题。我翻了一下你的领英，你职业生涯早期在摩根大通做高收益债券交易员。你有过一段被涂黑的百...
当时你管理着某种百万美元的交易组合。那段经历对你有什么影响，或者有什么疯狂的故事吗？那是你生命中四年时光。我觉得我学到了很多
后来在Anthropic以及其他工作中都用到了。在摩根大通的时候，交易大厅就像你想象的那种华尔街风格，但非常不同。大多数交易员我猜都是在终端前
他们更多的是在电脑上做分析。但那种环境还是男性主导的。我是那里唯一的女性，也是唯一有这种背景的人，在交易台上。而且
我学到的是，那是个很好的环境，一方面建立了我真实的自我感，另一方面，即使我是最资浅的人，即使我看起来与众不同，最好的想法和对最佳观点的坚持
才是最重要的，不管其他因素如何。所以我觉得带着那种态度去工作。我对团队很坦诚和真实。我努力确保
无论级别或资历如何，如果他们有好主意，会帮助他们去追求，同样我自己也这么做。就是把想法提出来，真正坚持，跟进
做那些琐碎的工作去实现它。这些都是我从交易中学到的。我觉得在很多方面适用于任何工作。
说得好。人们如果想关注你，在网上哪里能找到你？听众怎么才能帮到你？
我在社交媒体上不太活跃。我想最好的方式是通过Anthropic的博客找到我和团队的工作，当我们发布新模型或新体验时。至于
怎么帮我，第一就是你的反馈。实际上，如果你在任何产品上点赞或点踩，或者联系销售代表反馈模型问题，这些都会
传达给我。我们每个研究模型，我都会深入了解用户满意度和反馈。所以给我们反馈，推动Claude，告诉我们哪里不行，
这些都能帮我们改进Claude。另外，如果你的人脉里有我提到的那种人才，我正在招人，团队在扩大。我们真的喜欢那些热爱
技术、有深度好奇心、有第一性原理思维、敢于质疑假设、还有那种动手折腾精神的人。
哇，梦寐以求的工作。基本上就是开放式的产品经理岗位，在Anthropic的研究团队里。
是的。
我觉得他们应该是在官网的职业页面申请吧。
对。
天哪，太好了。好了，我们开始吧。准备好迎接你们将要收到的大量简历洪流吧。
谢谢。[笑声]
丹，非常感谢你来到这里。
非常感谢你邀请我。谢谢你那些非常有帮助、引发思考的问题，甚至帮我理清了我们如何工作、整个技术如何融合以及作为产品人员在其中如何定位的思路。
我真的很感激。但说真的，丹，谢谢你。好了，大家再见。非常感谢你们的收听。如果你觉得这期有价值，可以在Apple Podcast、Spotify或你最喜欢的播客应用上订阅我们的节目。另外，
请考虑给我们一个评分或留下评论，这真的能帮助其他听众发现这个播客。你可以在lennispodcast.com找到所有过往的节目或了解更多信息。我们下期见。